hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast utilizing available
biomarkers to tailor and individualized
therapy and diabetes presented by dr. J
Darrell we are excited to bring you this
educational webcast
presented by libraries and sponsored by
Dia Sauron the Sauron is a global leader
in the field of technology with the
presence in over 80 countries for over
40 years
via Sauron has been developing producing
and commercializing worldwide reagent
kits for the in vitro diagnostics market
in particular for the immuno diagnostics
and molecular diagnostic segment the
insurance products are specifically
designed for Hospital and private
testing laboratories their products menu
is unique for its width and presence of
specialty tests which identified the
asourian as a diagnostic specialist for
more information about our sponsor
visit www.sap.com/learnbi for today's
event before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green two-minute button located
in the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question in the box
that appears on the screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers three continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce dr. o JD Rao dr. Rao is a
board-certified
chronology specializing in diabetes in
cardiovascular disease at the Lewis Katz
School of Medicine at Temple University
in Philadelphia Pennsylvania dr. Ralph
completed his internal medicine
residency training at the Lincoln
clinical Medical Center in Burlington
Massachusetts and followed this with a
two-year Clinical Endocrinology
fellowship at the Tulane University
Health Sciences Center in New Orleans
Louisiana where he was involved in
landmark clinical trials in diabetes
such as accord in tinsel t2d he also
went through a critical-care fellowship
at the University of Pittsburgh Medical
Center in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania before
finishing a three-year research
fellowship at the Brigham and Women's
Hospital Harvard Medical School in
Boston Massachusetts dr. Rao also
received a master's in medical sciences
from the Harvard Medical School his
clinical expertise is in diabetes in
cardiovascular disease and has research
interest in diabetes in residual
cardiovascular risk please join me in
welcoming dr. o JD Rao I will now turn
the presentation over to him
thanks Julie for that kind introduction
and welcome everybody to this webinar
really pertaining to utilizing available
biomarkers to tailor individualized
therapies diabetes I'm a clinician I see
many patients with diabetes and have a
particular interest in cardiovascular
risk reduction you station I hope that
with this talk we'll all be able to
better manage these patients and help
them prevent have complications
I have no disclosures pertaining to this
particular presentation however I do to
see research support from novo in order
so briefly to provide an overview the
objectives of this talk to really
understand the epidemiology of type 1
and type 2 diabetes I would also like to
hopefully lean on these complexities
involved in distinguishing these type 1
from type 2 diabetes in the modern day
clinical setting and hopefully finally
we will understand the role of utilizing
the available biomarkers in order to
tailor therapies in diabetes so clearly
diabetes is a growing phenomenon across
the world this is a graph from the
United States CDC's division of diabetes
translation which clearly shows the
inflection of diagnosed diabetes and
percentage of individuals with diabetes
I've never even seen that of markets
increase over the last 15 to 20 years
many people have wondered if this has
been related to the way we diagnose
diabetes earlier approaches to
diagnosing
involves letting individual sugars get
up quite high before we actually
formally diagnosed them goodbye Jesus
however the recent slight Syria which we
will go over later in this talk a little
bit more stringent know probably
detecting individuals at an earlier
stage however having said all of that
clearly this rise in diagnosed IDs
parallels the epidemic of Chronicles and
nutrition and obesity as it pertains to
specifically type 2 diabetes now this is
giving the phenomena here in the United
States but clearly this is a growing
problem across the world including
Southeast Asia so there's a growing
population sizes specials and Chinese
similarly here's a sort of sweet map
which looks at age adjusted diabetes
prevalence rate reading United States
and as you can see here clearly there's
a potentially regional variation
therefore in the south of United States
there is a higher prevalence of age
adjusted guys news but as you can see
here we have a problem
throughout the country the best in urban
areas of the Northeast in the Midwest
and as you can see also Sumeria in the
Native American subset that there's a
really high incidence of diabetes this
heat map could probably be overlaid upon
by the rising epidemic of those visas
and other gangs of match that he's not
very similar this sort of breakdown has
been seen across the world but clearly
as I mentioned before growing problem
so close to probably about now 10% of
the United States population a little
bit of older data that I'm showing here
has diabetes the bulk of those
individuals has ties to deities and I
think what our concern is is that we
have many individuals who have diagnosed
diabetes you know hopefully trying to
get these individuals to their goals
prevent them from having any small
vessels or micro vascular complications
and also to risk modify the criteria to
prevent them from having cardiovascular
disease however what we're most
concerned about here with the
individuals who are undiagnosed these
are patients who are walking around and
do not know that they have died and at
this stage of their disease most likely
are without symptoms which makes sense
either at a higher risk it in hopes to
get this population to diagnosed and
hopefully we've had a lot more
nationwide efforts to screen individuals
for daizen of people thicker sooner than
later crucial part of treating diabetes
prevention of complication and this is a
slide from a couple years ago by Greg at
all new internal medicine where they
looked at trends in this
diabetes-related complications among
adults with diabetes for these the last
four years in the year the data now is
from 2010 so I think what can be clearly
noted here is that we have had a drop in
cardiovascular events if you see here in
red the acute myocardial infarction as
clearly gone down
over the years and this can similarly be
seen this stroke and these two entities
continue to happen with patients with
diabetes and heart disease remains the
number one cause of death mutation sadly
although it means a lot of efforts in
getting people controlled as it pertains
to their glucose control you still have
the same event rate for a known
microvascular complications then stage
renal disease so you clearly need some
more efforts to target those populations
being dropped in acute myocardial
infarction and Stroke probably has to do
more with evidence-based care it seems
within those entities so that the modern
approach to an acute myocardial
infarction or heart attack as actually
actually become quite refined and
optimized and patients seem much better
further we have other non glucose
lowering therapies such as statin
therapy or other LDL lowering therapies
at the fittings to cholesterol which has
also helped this drop include myocardial
infarction and probably also stroke but
one thing I want to remind you all is
that even after these huge efforts we've
made we still have a pretty high
residual cardiovascular risk losing
patience so when we treat our patients
is both type 1 and type 2 diabetes we
clearly have the heart in mind
so how do we define diabetes knowledge
this is a standard classical diagnosis
from the World Health Organization and
several decades ago which noted that the
definition of diabetes really good is
syndromes of disordered metabolism with
inappropriate hyperglycemia due to
either an absolute deficiency of
influence or reductions in the biologic
effectiveness of insulin or both
and when hopefully we'll get this
definition clearly there is two parts of
it one is these inappropriate
hyperglycemia the patient's have but
also that is related to either an
absolute sufficiency of insulin which we
typically see in type 1 diabetes or a
reduction in the biologic effectiveness
of insulin so there's two parts of it
both the glucose and insulin and when
these things of type 1 diabetes or what
we used to call juvenile diabetes you
think about and have these sufficiency
events in and when we think about a 2
diabetes you think about reductions in
the biologic effectiveness but one thing
that is very important to remember is
that many individuals with type 2
diabetes end up having age-related
declines in their abilities to make it
so these individuals relatively become
absolutely efficient here are the
criteria for diagnosis advising nowadays
so the first rings criteria need to be
repeated so that either have a fasting
plasma glucose greater than or equal to
126 milligrams per deciliter or 7
millimoles per liter
fasting is defined as no caloric intake
for at least eight hours Walter could
have a two-hour plasma glucose greater
than or equal to 200 during an oral
glucose tolerance test the test should
be performed as described by these World
Health Organization's using glucose load
containing the equivalent of 75 grams
and hydrates because dissolved in water
and finally the third criteria which can
be done in the clinical settings is a a1
fees later than for peaceful 26.5%
so this is the hemoglobin agency the a13
measurements has been verified as being
strictly correlated to microvascular
compensation and had historically been
used for a long time for assessing and
surveillance operations with treated
diabetes however in the last 5-10 years
with the team part of the diagnostic
criteria and this is great since this
allows individuals not to need to be
fasting or have to get through an oral
glucose low the one caveat is that these
tests is still being refined and it
needs to be performed in the certified
laboratory in a standardized fashion the
other important feature to remember is
that there are individuals who can have
variations in their Aseema global
measurements either physics Armenia or
other related issues with their blood
count that could fall to lower their a1c
and then this may not be the ideal test
to choose it's the key thing to remember
for any one of the first please tests
you need a receipt of that test now this
could be done by repeating the same test
or which could be done by measuring
you separate tests on one sample what
our hope is that hopefully we are able
to detect more of those undiagnosed
patients isn't help them better manage
their disease now finally there are
patients who present with what we call
classic symptoms of elevated sugars or
potentially might be crisis mode so
these are people who might between the
woods tea rooms they may have urgently
come in to us women or they're already
hospitalized
these sanctions are having classic
symptoms of hyperglycemia that is
urinating a lot thirsty a lot and
they're random glucose elevated and
those individuals can be diagnosed right
then and there because of the classic
symptoms and the elevated sugars so on
closer examination of this diagnostic
criteria when we can clearly see it is
dictated by the circulating glucose
levels and or a measure of bulkiness
variability we are focusing on
perturbations on glucose and as you can
notice here there's really no commentary
about what the circulating insulin
levels are effective uses or afarid
efficiency here is a slide of these
approved anti-diabetic medications in
United States I place this slide here
just to show that we've had a dramatic
decrease in the amount of we're
medication over the last four years but
at the same time you can see that their
effectiveness when it comes to their use
as a single nature as it relates to
reduction in hemoglobin a1c may not be
thought to be that great influence has
been around for a long time
the early 1920s and clearly has a
ability to reduce a1c by close to two
and a half percent now when we look at
the agents that have been recently
approved it's important to note that
most of them will be used in combination
with metformin which is one of the more
commonly used first-line agent in type 2
diabetes but again the slide here
focuses on reduction in average glucose
and the importance of potentially
utilizing combination therapy the other
things to note is due to experience with
one diabetic agent all new diabetic
agents that are used in type 2 diabetes
and in fact even in various newer
insulin formulations are mandated by not
only the United States Food and Drug
Administration but even in European
agencies to have a defined
cardiovascular outcome study mostly
because again the number one cause of
death in the patient remains
cardiovascular disease and we would like
to choose anti-diabetic agents that are
safe for the heart so it's really made
is a very interesting arena the
permissions are able to now choose
appropriate therapies for their patients
but it also makes a much more complex if
we want to make sure we're choosing the
right agents by the right patient so
talk a little bit about heart disease
earlier slide the clearly there is a
well-known link between diabetes and
cardiovascular disease when we have
classes in thought of the metabolic
syndrome we think of individuals who are
in these deep hypertensive difficult
Edenic patients who have this the
collections as native the metabolic
syndrome another high this for
cardiovascular disease
clearly there are also probably infants
from other entities such as stroke or
for artery disease and from these
outcome trials of newer ages as it
pertains to diabetes specifically type 2
diabetes you've learned a lot more about
the relationship of heart failure and
type 2 diabetes that this might be
something that you need to ask of
patients more about as that might be a
predictor of future events in addition
patients may have reservations out there
as rhythms so they could have heart
rhythms that could have disturbances
such as atrial fibrillation and this can
lead to things such as stroke in the
future
so clearly diabetics are at higher risk
for cardiovascular disease probably
mediated a lot to obesity at the tension
disability mass but also numerous
so is a biomarker utilize these
Commission's to help patients assess
these some of the studies we will be
into effects of biomarkers in variety of
research setting so classic and define a
biomarker is in statistics that is
objectively measured and evaluated as
imitator of normal biological oddities
academic prophecies or pharmacologic
responses to the therapeutic
intervention so clearly for us here in
diabetes we are looking for biomarkers
that correlates well this not only
pathogenic processes but probably also
how an individual responds to a
pharmacological therapy so what are the
available biomarkers that we have what
are the students that review
so two trees that are well tested and
has been utilized in the clinical
settings for a long time include urine
micro albumin they show with the
measurement of Coaching excretion and
from the kidneys clearance it is an idea
of potentially early damage in diabetes
and also as I mentioned before the a1c
not only utilized for diagnostic
criteria but it also can have a lot of
benefit when it comes to monitoring
patients and it's a good predictor of
outcomes in these patients not only
small vessel or micro vascular outcome
but probably also large vessel or
massive absolute so
there wells pestis biomarkers so they
should have probably high level of
evidence singular as the established
guideline
so here is the urine microalbuminuria
ratio and the statements that the
American Diabetes Association's make
promise
so in individuals who are non pregnant
who have thises resistant hypertension
either an angiotensin converting enzyme
inhibitor or an angiotensin receptor
blocker is recommended for those with
modestly elevated urinary calcium
excretion that's a level B evidence and
strongly recommended for patients with
urinary albumin excretion greater than
or you so choose 300 milligrams per
grams creatinine and/or summated GFR
less than six base employee see there
that's a level a supreme give us data to
back utilization of those agents for
hypertension management or cosmetic
management so we talked about the other
biomarker how is it helpful as we gauge
the patient's response to therapy so
interestingly if you look at the
American Diabetes Association statement
about monitoring patient's they
mentioned that continuing monitoring of
winner albumin is Batman ratio in
patients who already have known a loser
on an ACE inhibitor or nal G it's
reasonable to assess treatment response
and progression of diabetic now sadly to
the level sees evidence when this expert
in evidence and the problem is this is
that in both in non diabetics and
diabetic subjects microalbuminuria is
associated with an increased
cardiovascular risk and key thing here
is that it is independent of knowing
this determinant say a very low
reputable biomarkers I've had issues
when it comes to realize
surveillance for managing therapeutic
response so we tried to tease out this a
little bit in a small study that we did
several years ago where we try to check
another u9 marker which may be more
related has a physiological proxies that
are underlined here we actually assess
urinary of Ostrom it is an individual
who had well controlled type 2 diabetes
and on appropriate lipid-lowering
therapy and most importantly appropriate
ring an angiotensin aldosterone system
blockades so they're leading to t4
either an inhibitor or an agent Henson's
receptor blocker and as you can see here
what we did was is the actually assess
urinary aldosterone measurement on the
x-axis and a 24-hour urine collection
and we also have the ability to measure
non-invasively cardiac fibrosis and this
is just one the y-axis the myocardial at
cellular volume which is a measurement
and non-invasive measurement of cardiac
fibrosis may ask why cardiac fibrosis is
important well it probably is one of the
key features of the early processes of
the diabetic cardiomyopathy or the
diabetic heart disease and it clearly
has a relationship for many preclinical
studies with the hormones a lobster I
think what's important to note here is
that these individuals were already on
base in addition a maximum when they
still had excursions of a urinary
aldosterone measure and that B is
correlated with these fibrosis patients
now who are specific may not be with us
here but clearly we know that there are
many other things that go into the very
vania fibrosis in a particular human but
still pretty important to note that
there is a
significant correlation of this
biomarker another thing to recognize
here is those individuals with even
undetectable urinary aldosterone levels
our baseline may have had problems with
fibrosis moving with no XSL valves
building the circulation so clearly we
probably need additional biomarkers to
assist in prevention of murex these
which clearly has an association with
cardiovascular outcomes another way of
looking at this we provided the 24-hour
urine a lobster roll measurement which
is either greater than or equal to
medium a lobster and levels in the urine
versus less than Julian and as you can
see here those individuals who had
higher than or equal to meet Ian values
for their L box four levels clearly had
higher audio fibrosis as measured by the
extracellular volume that had ended
non-invasive and the statistically
significant so again in bed an
appropriate biomarker is either in micro
elements that you ratio could we use
Brunel Box manases perhaps better
markers as this probably place more with
the underline at the Jennie fossa now
this could be similar even if you look
at the other end of the spectrum which
is regulation of glucose and insulin
metabolism
we'll assume that is nice to measure the
actual hormone that's involved in the
disease such as infant so here is a
simple study for the old studies from
Quebec Canada where they actually
investigated odds ratios for heart
disease according to plasma insulin
concentration so what I want to end
here is that the x-axis fear is
completely related to infant levels and
those are split up into three levels and
then the various fear are known
cardiovascular risk factors these are
the climb is probably safe today
collect various measures of cholesterol
and also various measures of remnants
lipoproteins are remnants cholesterol
which probably has a physiological
significance edges of a damage to these
other vascular system and as you can see
here in these turtles of insulin levels
of higher turtle clearly had the highest
odds ratio for cardiovascular disease
really irrespective of where they stood
when it came to loans cardiovascular
risk factors so we would assume that
this might be something very important
to the clinician to affect yet when you
look at the available guidelines in the
American Diabetes Association clearly we
are focused on glucose lowering and if
you look at this slide there is clear 15
from a VA considered therapy based on
what their levels of sugar
so essentially what the patient comes in
with will put a sort of a choice of
therapy so here you are going to start
mono therapy unless their sugar is
clearly elevated with most likely oral
agents your specifically focusing on
type 2 diabetes and then we will move on
to dual therapy or even triple therapy
with oil regions in individuals who have
higher sugar
there's no individualization 56 years in
the therapist and a lot of this has to
do with the concept that we spent almost
two different decades making sure that
patients retreated to target and I think
that's the focus that this guide which
is probably reasonable at a population
level
now since this guideline is focused here
in the United States there is also a lot
of commentary about the cost-benefit
ratio so as you can see there each agent
is given off and also there is
commentary on efficacy risk for side
effects and which for I'll be pleased
low sugars which is something everybody
lost to prevent clearly there's a group
of patients here we're going to consider
injectable therapy Sameer is an
algorithm again focused on maderas
equals negative moment and giving these
appropriate guidelines but how to start
these them how to utilize them to them
and how to utilize other injectables as
add-on therapy choosing freely and as
you can see here again there is focus on
treating the target changing therapies
based on what the person says oh that's
the most control here which is clearly
an important thing again has to probably
be the dealer so why is this always for
and the reason is that we have a view of
diabetes selection simply if you think
about indigenous with either type 1 or
type 2 diabetes there's some types of
sort of several hits these patients they
may be at risk they may have something
else that happens mix of this at this
time period and they are going to fall
into categories
- so if you look at long-standing
literature in this field this is now
focusing more on probably type 1
diabetes you can see that there's
individuals who are genetically at-risk
to begin with and those individuals are
able to compensate with their sugars
being at a relatively normal value for
some time and then there is sort of
expected precipitating event that occurs
and this clearly causes the degeneration
in their glucose levels and then that
developers ID now in type 1 diabetes
there's been a hope that we can capture
some of these individuals is this
disease settings hopefully to try to
prevent them from having a work beta
cell mass loss and prevent them from
having over diabetes but as you can see
here there's commentary about another
way of measuring these women dodging the
system which is the c-peptide levels
whether it's present or not session and
this might be an important feature to
consider when we manage patients with
diabetes so what are the differences
between type 1 and type 2 dice and are
they usually pretty clear-cut so
classically the thought of type 1
diabetes as a disease that occurs in
young individuals so we used to talk
about because juvenile diabetes we
expect that these patients will have
cavities is more abrupt presentation at
the post to type 2 diabetes which might
include over time the type 1 individuals
may have classic symptoms of polyuria
polydipsia and our surrogates for their
level of insulin assistance has usually
been measurement to 5
both those you are overweight probably
have more of a type 2 diabetes picture
those religions who are not as similar
to public type 1 diabetes picture and in
these patients who have type 1 diabetes
they have severe deficiencies they
rarely have insulin resistance the type
1 diabetics clearly is one therapy so
that's been our classical use like
finishing these two diseases but let me
just talk about okay let's subscribe and
maybe shed some light on this topic so
the patient that I saw recently it's a 2
year old male be presented with what his
provider had mentioned as quote both
brittle guidance he was diagnosed three
years prior to his current visit whose
a1c which is used here the monitor his
control was around ten point six percent
he was started appropriately of an oral
agents and titrated up on that agent he
did not have in the BMI and the life on
him his current a1c was eight point
seven percent so instead of usable
response so the question is here is type
two diabetes mellitus that correct
diagnosis for this patient is there
anything else you should be assessing
for this patient to determine if you are
missing something or the approach to be
different so one thing to remember is
you know my new portion of the
population probably in places where
there is a higher prevalence of type one
dies about tenfold 10 percent of adults
may have something called latent
autoimmune diabetes in adults
learn a lot these individuals will have
circulating Auto antibodies actually
directed against the pancreatic
beta-cell so these Mason and I have what
we call I would sell antibodies or gad65
antibodies simply time audacity
carboxylate antibody so these are the
antibodies that are sort of Sevilla and
it comes to classic type one diabetes it
surprisingly there is a portion of
adults who also have some circulating
life-size antibodies and they're adults
they're not children um they don't
require a diagnosis but they progressed
to using dependent or need after several
months two years and perhaps in these
patients the presents and titers of
those antibodies Krita sista and help us
identify patient's thought to have
traditional type 2 diabetes so going
back to our case that might be something
that female consider indication again
that is assessing their antibody levels
you can go back to our algorithms
clearly there's not any commentary about
the measurements of that antibodies at
any sort of level and it's not really a
discussion about whether we should
consider testing abof antibodies or
other measures of AC institutions and as
you can see here we may wonder whether
it's actually helpful to order insulin
levels are helpful to account for into
insufficient by the body because as I
mentioned before clearly is a high risk
of cardiovascular disease for those
individuals with higher circulating
insulin levels
is the role of assessing insulin
secretion so insulin is produced by in
the pancreatic beta cells by cleavage of
the prohormone precursor protein to
putting its influence and seat up by an
equal molar now so this is one of the
crucial reasons we utilize the peptide
as a surrogate for informed decisions
some imagined sources see peptide has a
longer half-life that in phonemic
speculation on one problem with insulin
assays is that the endogenous insulin
will be detected by the uniform aspect
so if an individual is already on
instance specific challenges assess
their insulin levels and peripheral
insulin levels may not accurately
reflect what is really the important
feature which is a vigorous
portal in solution and this is even the
same even in non decent treating
patients so the impact of a given level
of institutions will depend on an
individual insulin resistance so what
I'm trying to say is that if a person is
already including resistance then the
additional decent secretion problems
will make management a little bit more
difficult and probably should be again
individualized choice of therapy should
probably be a bit different even in
patients who separately have declining
anticipation if they have additional
resistance
this will cause diabetes to develop
earlier and and the final issue here is
that all these things from resistant
patients they have normal or even -
setsize levels at their presentations
even if they have autoimmune type 1
diabetes as these things seem to thicken
as one from
available biomarkers and this is where
we've had some difficulty recently
because many patients with type 1
diabetes can prevent positive that means
bodies phenotype so the si si si has
clearly had recent improvement the non
isotopic si so in essence the lesson
there's still problems with optimal
standardization but success may be
worked on to the radio and the
concerning thing of course is set
factors for set reference ranges for
specific populations about meaning
should a white population or
predominantly white population is a
difference and avenge them may be the
Asian suspect and this is still yet to
keep out now one may ask well why not
just measure interest and so this has
been looked at extensively about post
announced from years ago maybe a numeric
values relations taskforce tribes trying
to standardize enzyme assays because of
historic result and reason for the six
pitfalls are multiple but I think these
crucial ones to remember here are
individuals who have circulating anti
incident Auto antibodies because render
the axes really uninterpretable and then
of course the activities of individuals
who are on exogenous interests a
graphics and along accidents in analog
which patients use as a common inversion
vision makes it difficult to assess
infinitely fine
not all in fun assays our defense say
they not all internet we have acceptable
performance characteristics that are
needed for large-scale population wise
limited and the work group from the ABA
the work is concluded that not all
commercial assets were able to measure
influence that acceptable precision
accuracy of proxy activity which again
makes it a problem in the assessing
things at a population level
so in summary there's clearly a need for
individualizing therapy inviting
assessments of insulin secretion is
crucial in patients where the available
technical education of diabetes is not
so clear I hope that the case that I
presented today hopefully give you an
impression that this can be a little bit
of a confusing picture in a lot of
patients c-peptide can be used as a
marker of intensification but as you can
see there are some pitfalls these
immunizations but on a knitted
individual basis it may have some
utility for sure on sadly you still need
a lot of harmonization when it comes to
info and access platform but definitely
we are moving in the right direction for
again population-wide recommendation and
most importantly we're hoping that
accurate meaningful laboratory
assessment will improve and optimize
patient care decided well I hope you
learned a lot about diabetes and I hope
understand the goal is to capsize we
move into and a half days in these
patients thank you
Thank You dr. Ralph for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window tap your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well insert
as many of your questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
questions dr. rau will follow up with
you via email after the presentation
let's get started our first question is
are there other conditions besides
diabetes where measurements of insulin
and or c-peptide may be helpful
so it's a great question so see topside
and insulin measurement section have a
role in other diseases that are probably
outside of the diabetes well I think the
the fundamental place where we use it a
lot as an endocrinologist It didn t work
up individuals who don't have diabetes
and are having problems with low blood
sugars so they have hypoglycemia and
what we're trying to figure out is
whether these individuals have excess
insulin from a source and their bodies
such as this will be called ECMO mark
which can happen very rarely and what's
helpful is impaired measurement of
c-peptide and influence that you can
hopefully distinguish where this problem
is coming from whether it's endogenous
influence equation or dysregulated
endogenous insufficient for them as I
mentioned it means aroma or potentially
if it is related to somebody
unfortunately you see this once in a
while what we call fictitious disorders
people who are injecting insulin is
inclined to gain attention from the
healthcare personnel there the c-peptide
in some levels would be very informative
along with other screens to see what's
in your circulation so that's I guess
the hypoglycemia condition or the low
blood sugar condition without diabetes
could be a case where this is evaluated
and needed and societies don't happen
very good question
thank you for that answer we're going to
wrap up with just one more question and
that question is do two typically
measure C peptide and insulin levels on
all of your patients prior to treatment
for diabetes yeah that's that's also a
very good question that in a population
wise type of question I think it's very
difficult to assess these assays for
each and every individual clearly an
example of this you can see is probably
the case that I presented I think when
there's any questions of the diagnosis
and I have lots of users fooled a lot
about people who you think have sort of
cut type 2 diabetes that might have one
of these sort of a typical forms of
diabetes or even have actually type 1
diabetes I think they're the c-peptide
levels is helpful in garnering is to say
to go v Inc they're asking people who
have utilized paired insulin and glucose
measurements as an indicator of
circulating insulin resistance but as I
already spoke about in this talk I think
one of the problems is standardization
of insulin assays and probably more
importantly is capturing individuals at
the command of diagnosis one fortunate
human bill we have by a large scale
evidence that change the levels
correlate with this downstream events
it's still hard to recommend that at a
population level but clearly the
c-peptide levels as an active role and
we utilize that on a day-to-day basis
when we're trying to assess endogenous
insulin secretion and individuals
disease
I would like to once again thank dr.
Ralph for his presentation do you have
any final comments well I hope everybody
enjoys the sauce and I think the most
important thing here is helping our
patients this is a disease that's
growing across the world event mentioned
earlier and we really need to figure out
ways to individualize therapies you have
a lot of pharmaceutical options in this
city businesses we have to be a better
job as making sure the patient's are
healthy walking to be themselves
exercising and active and we also have a
lot of work to be that individualized
therapy for patients to hopefully move
in the right direction and hopefully
learn about the Stasi once again dr.
Rowe I would also like to thank lab
roots and be a soren for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 13
2018 you will receive an email from
labrys letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye